let's do this heck yes yes alright
what's up everyone we are back at Women
in Technology International and we are
seeing down with Radhika Iyengar Evans
correct hello hello thank you for
joining us thank you for having me
we really appreciate it and we are going
to talk about all the incredible work
that you guys have been doing this
blockchain consulting and all and also
the future of what this technology is
gonna be like yeah big stuff happening
big stuff is happening was so what I
always like to ask this to people that
are buying the blockchain technology
moving forward is how did you even find
out about the technology in the first
place
crypto investing crypto investing like
two years ago or how many years yeah
about a year and a half ago I'd say when
I started doubling and it was really
more so in theory in Bitcoin but then I
started getting into alts so obviously
last year was a decent year and this
year we've been in a bear market I don't
see that changing to too much I'm not
going to give any grand predictions or
anything about this year for various
reasons it's been kind of having a tough
time this year but that's how I got into
it but what really got me excited was my
way of health care so I'm a digital
health care expert and when I looked at
the technology itself fundamentally as a
technology and it's applications in
healthcare I got really excited in fact
I really haven't been this excited about
a technology in a really long time so
it's it feels amazing to be part of this
and if you're at all in the blockchain
space you understand the people that are
involved in this space are just hopping
right now II know these it's electric
energy every single event you go to I I
was just recently at consensus in New
York yeah and they were I think
forecasting 4,000 people I think they
said that it was about 8,500 and I think
it felt like 10 12,000 people it was
amazing woah a totally amazing
experience and it was all week long
so yeah that's kind of the energy factor
that we're talking about and Silicon
Valley is I'd say you know a little bit
behind in terms of the technology aspect
that concur to many other parts of the
world but I think it's catching on
feverishly here too so
my colleagues and I are involved very
much in a lot of the events and programs
and exciting stuff that's happening in
space so you were digital health before
this I still AM so now I evangelize on
blockchain in healthcare society note a
lot of conferences these days
I dunno mark essa essa moderated the
women in blockchain panel at global
blocking forum and she's amazing so yes
and who is the other person that's kind
of an SME sent her partner Mason I don't
know Vanessa
I dunno Marchesa yeah she and I are both
in the healthcare space yeah both sound
cool passionate and excited about the
future of healthcare has enabled and
amplified and enhanced by watching yes
yes I'm glad that this is now something
that you are even going to things like
the massive consensus event doing panels
about it
so let's oh man I'm happy that you know
we we have a good amount of intros I
think that can help one another with all
we're both doing which is fantastic so
the so a managing partner at double Nova
Group so that's been doing blockchain
strategy now yeah well our background as
double nova has been more so enabling
companies to scale to grow to do
fundraising activities here in the
valley to connect ecosystems a lot of
the work we do is International which is
another aspect that I like watching so
much is that it is global but as della
Nova we've worked with companies around
the world we've worked with governments
and accelerators running programs
showcasing technologies that come out of
those ecosystems building bridges across
ecosystems and so that's you know our
background on my backgrounds as a serial
entrepreneur and my colleague as well
and so we've gotten involved in all of
that in the past and I've been involved
in digital health probably about six
years or so was very active on the
leadership team of health 2.0 Silicon
Valley still have a lot of good friends
in that net space and collaborated with
them on numerous programs as well and
you know when I came across blockchain
as I meant
and I was really looking at that
application of watching in healthcare
and I thought wow this is tremendously
transformative we may have to you know
crawl before we walk before you run
their paces and we fall after we react
exactly so I mean though there's there's
paces that the technology has to take
obviously this is a relatively new
technology and it has to go through its
throes of growing but the application
and and and the future it promises is
really exciting so yeah but anyway
that's kind of the background with
double nova and what we're doing these
days is helping companies with
implementing watch-chain strategy yes so
let's get to how you're doing the like
giving examples of implementation and
while we do this examples of
implementation we can do just a very
quick definition of the technology for
people as well decentralized and
beautiful but no there's really no very
well yeah just keep it forwards but you
know and so like let's give an example
let's um so I think let's talk about
maybe just a rough idea of what's
watching is blockchain is really a
distributed ledger technology think of
it like a very sophisticated spreadsheet
of sorts whereas one spreadsheet might
be centralized you have up the whole
spreadsheet on in one location
blockchain is kind of a distributed
ledger so it's the information is
distributed across many different points
or nodes right the I guess the four
pillars that we talked about my
colleague wrote a paper on this the four
pillars of blockchain are as you
mentioned the immutability ultra secure
aspects of watching the records and
themselves and the security level around
that number two is decentralization we
talked about centralized versus
decentralized almost everything that we
know today is centralized and therefore
offers a single point of failure as we
call it so blockchain is completely
decentralized then the third thing is
gamification so if you've known anything
about video game world and everything is
gamified incentivized and so blockchain
offers a community aspect that is also
incentivized so you sent
is the behavior of the community not
only on the user side but also the
developer site so it's very much of a
community effort and then it's also
gamified and intense incentivized that's
a very different shift from what we have
all been used to so far and then the
last thing is open source software so
there's no proprietary IP it's all open
source so it makes for a really exciting
environment because it gets everybody
involved in this and thinking about
things in a completely new manner
it's the scope of what that offers which
make button which makes blockchain very
interesting now a lot of people think of
blockchain and they think of maybe did
coin and and so the difference is
Bitcoin a theory a mold those are
cryptocurrencies they're examples of the
application of blockchain but they're
it's not equivalent to blotting
blockchain itself it's a technology that
you use and so what's exciting about
blockchain is that when you start
looking and there and not all the block
chains are created equal not all block
chains are ultra you know just the ultra
secure aspect of it itself it's not just
the one element that has to be there if
you have multiple elements there that's
when it really becomes ultra secure so
blockchain is now being used with really
sophisticated encryption technologies
the background of blockchain is really
from cryptography so we've got some
really exciting cryptographic techniques
that are now in Irvan with blockchain
technology to be able to offer the kinds
of things that are having CIOs awake at
night these days so everything around
data all of the debacles that we've been
seeing with Mirjana lytic all of these
things that we are now hearing about
that we've known about but are really I
think the consciousness is more alive
around that right now in terms of the
problems we have with around that and so
everybody's thinking about well what
happens to my data right and so if you
want privacy security trust identity all
of those things really protected around
your data blockchain has a capability
along with cryptographic techniques to
be able to enable that then you get even
more exciting with blockchain if you
start marrying that with deep tech so a
IML or
tea or other BTech sort of technologies
that confluence of technologies then
becomes even more compelling so this is
kind of the future that we're seeing
watching what do we do with companies
when we talk about blockchain strategy
that just depends on the company right I
mean what's exciting is that if you're a
small company or a large company you can
implement blockchain you can use
blockchain so it could be an existing
company that says you know I've got some
issues with supply chain and I want to
be able to track all of the different
components down the line I want to be
able to audit all of it I want to know
the provenance of all of this and so
that's a great use case for example in
blockchain my panel tomorrow in the
morning we'll be talking about use cases
my perspective is on healthcare but us
as a panel will be talking about
real-world applications of blockchain so
you know anybody can really look at the
benefits that blockchain offers and so
what we do is work with companies
sometimes to figure out well what does
that look like what are the kind of
problems you're having right now is it
around identity and Trust is it around
you know do you want to incentivize
behaviors within your community for
example do you want to have audit trails
or transparency across your data so
there's many different things that the
law chain can do it something to
understand what your objective is and
then to help you develop a roadmap of
how do you implement blockchain to be
able to arrive at the solutions that you
are looking for so that's in a very
large umbrella like what we do you did a
really good job of explaining it thank
you yeah yeah spent a long time with it
yeah yeah and the all of the nuance of
the technology and its importance can be
applied in different ways to different
companies correct exactly and there
there's some you know what's exciting is
with any nuoc technology there's
obviously going to be some low-hanging
fruit as far as applications right
things that have been plaguing people
and you know the thorns on our side so
to speak and more urgent thorns and they
might be you know when you think about
it they might be seemingly simple but it
can be saved
companies thousands or hundreds of
thousands or millions of dollars right
pharmaceutical companies for example are
really excited about what blockchain can
offer because all of the issues that
many pharmaceutical companies have been
having with counterfeiting of drugs fake
drugs right can solve this by the use of
blockchain because as you know from
using the block the chain of the blocks
that are in the chain is that once the
record is in the blockchain it's
immutable I can't be changed and so when
you think about all of these
recommendations parents the problem to
have the potential breach of a
blockchain with the network being
controlled by only a certain amount of
groups that have over 50% of the mining
control you know the thing is that the
there are many different ways
so not all block chains as I mentioned
are created equal and there are many
different ways to prevent those kinds of
situations from happening you know
without getting too technical in this
interview I just suffice it to say but
there are there are many different ways
that you can solve that problem the 51%
attack that you're talking about
obviously from a theoretical standpoint
it can be done but it has to be done in
you know with enormous computing power
to be able to do that kind of thing all
at once if you have the more nodes you
have the more difficult that gets to
pull that off and the beauty of
blockchain is once you've written it in
then you're not going to be able to go
back and do it so in order to retrace
your steps and I don't know forge
something or fraudulently represent
something really difficult to do really
difficult to do it's not something
that's gonna be totally just
automatically now massive mining farms
and when they're in control by only a
couple people that can commute and and
those are considerations that you have
to look at and the thing is that it's
that's the proof-of-work model if you're
doing the proof of stake model that's a
different model all together again
don't want to get too too technical
about this but there's many different
ways you can do this I mean I think if
you were in the early days and you're
doing Bitcoin whatever then that's the
proof of work model there's not proof of
stake and so that's a very different
model that we're seeing state doesn't
have the 51% attack not you know again
it's it's what proof of work has more
more capability of being able to do that
again it depends on the computing power
so people are saying well if you have
quantum computing computing you can do
this sort of thing yes theoretically
absolutely as possible but quantum
community computing is I think a little
bit away so we have a tiny edge right
now I'm not saying that that edge is
going to last forever because I think
hackers as much as developers you know
or people are developing this are
progressing at rapid rates so I'm not
gonna say not going to be completely you
know untouchable forever but what we
have right now is a whole lot better
than what the problems of we it's the
beginning of the decentralisation
movement yes and so right before on the
way to quantum computing will continue
stress testing let's have knowledge
correct in many different ways and make
it better over time
so and I think that you know I'm glad
we're talking about all of this because
it kind of segues into my thesis as well
as my colleagues thesis on the beauty of
a more enterprise right now we are
sitting at a point where Enterprise is
really starting to take off we're
talking you know just thousands and
thousands and thousands of projects
right 37,000 projects that are out there
pilots and way more than I cos have in
enterprise well what is what is a hot
enterprise pilot mean it means that they
are testing out implementation in a
pilot case and to see how successful it
is but there are a lot of pilots going
on in so us the u.s. there's 37,000 I
think well that's a very good question I
think in the US and these are mostly
enterprise software right it is and so
the thing is that with enterprise what
we're finding is and now you want to
apply blockchain technology to that
right exactly and and the enterprise is
very much looking at this they're
already looking at the pharma industry
as I've mentioned is really excited
about this insurance tech is looking at
this there's a lot of different sectors
manufacturing logistics these are all
areas that are looking at this angle
this is an amazing use case coming out
of this technology so
I think the beauty of where we are in
enterprise is a lot of the enterprise
applications are moving into more public
permissioned chains for access control
yes exactly and so you know you're
working with trusted nodes so if you
know anything about the nodes systems in
blockchain this again comes down to that
whole hack ability and you know how do
you do the 51% attacks etc if you're
looking at enterprise systems they're
all almost all right now going to be
looking at permission chains right
IBM hyper ledger fabric for example JP
Morgan's quorum for example these are
all permission chains right and so when
you think about permission chains you're
basically saying look it's not the big
public at large kind of thing that
everybody's still been talking about its
trusted nodes and because they're
trusted nodes you're going to be less
vulnerable to that extent because you've
kind of vetted out who has access to all
of this the general hospital' can tap
into your biometric data
it's a trusted node right it's a trusted
node in and so trusted stakeholders in
the ecosystem right and so when you're
talking about that you're gonna say well
security level might be not quite so
high but then you get a lot of
transaction speeds as well because now
you're able to control what happens
within that controlled environment so to
speak and so what we're seeing in the
next two years is that enterprise is
going to be just hopping out of yeah 50
million dollar fine you know five
billion we're starting charge starting
with a bite size I mean obviously
there's more there's more but that's
that's our goal with stretching ventures
our thesis is is actually focused on
enterprise blockchain and so we're and
also foundational technologies and
protocols like I mentioned because what
we're seeing where we're at in terms of
logic we it's a funky road of cost
because we'll let's get there but on the
way you mention these massive industries
and are you hyper targeting then pharma
and insurance where those like are these
like the big dawgs who else are the big
dogs right now I would say anybody
that's in FinTech in logistics and
manufacturing in pharma in insurance
tech even healthcare I mean there's a
lot of different sectors that are
looking at this I would say just we
watch every that's pretty much everybody
I mean it has a transformative potential
in terms of what's going to happen when
and how quickly obviously that's the
crystal ball question right we are so
just gonna go it's gonna go first
I mean I think that you know we have a
lot of amazing use cases that's the
that's the beauty I mean if you look at
the way banks are implementing this for
example we the more expensive items like
maybe a car which is gonna or you know
things that are in one maybe a dose like
a pharmaceutical is also very can be
very expensive with their drugs for
orphan diseases that's one use case but
another use cases for example specific
luxury goods or like wine or that kind
of thing it's a it can be a luxury good
thing well how do I know that thing is
not fake food all right fake news
there's that too actually there's a
greeny core company out of China
that is called Primus that's working on
the whole fake news aspect of things
right pretty intense
if you look they're pretty intense it's
all the difference if you look at the
essence of blockchain it's really to
bring that transparency to what we're
doing and so the people that are
involved in counterfeit activities and
take anything it's really going to put
that entire world topsy-turvy right and
then this has this technology has that
exciting potential again as far as what
kinds of use cases we're seeing in the
near term like 18 months 24 months kind
of timeline pretty much Enterprise I
would say that's really where the action
is that yeah if you think of you know
the dot-com days and how that played out
again a lot of people tend to not
remember very accurately or just
conveniently forget or what have you
that you know what was the first biggest
e-commerce site back in the day
eBay Cisco Cisco yeah and what do they
make they make routers router yeah they
made wire structure yeah right and so
you think about that they go they had
the biggest e-commerce site that was
like the 7a 80s
well actually Cisco and the big that I
think that was actually 94 so I mean I
think that what's what's really cool is
you know we're going through the throws
right that's that's the most important
thing to remember is when you look at
any emerging technology there's going to
be an adoption curve you have to start
somewhere there are going to be some
important things that we have to resolve
in blockchain like transaction speeds
like the energy usage for example and so
when you think about proof of work with
versus proof of stake there's a big
difference there in terms of the energy
consumption work like a couple like oh
but that one has well that's more very
very big and so what you're talking is a
lot of people complain about that thing
well the energy consumption is so high
again you have to think about what is
the end result right start with that
that's why we work well it might be it
might might be ultra security if you're
you know a banker and you're
transferring just tremendously high
volume of dollars or currency somewhere
you want the ultra sized security you
might compromise on speed but you'll say
I want I don't want to compromise on
security so again what is the end goal
this comes down to that strategy portion
right start with that end goal what do
you really want out of it prioritize
what you want out of it and then we
dictate how you're going to implement it
what you're willing to say I'm willing
to you know balance the trade-offs
it's always about trade-offs right it's
never gonna be that perfect perfect
perfect right okay so what are the
trade-offs and prioritize what you want
so that you can say I'm willing to
compromise on X or Y because I really
want Z right and so that's the kind of
thing that you have to go out with you
think through and that's what we help
companies do is evaluate where do you
want to be and how do you even are you
going to implement this and what are the
trade-offs involved and how do you
figure out a roadmap that makes sense
for you so it's as we consult with
companies and they figure out how to
implement this technology within the
organization that's figuring out the
balance between between the trade-offs
meanwhile the technology is gonna figure
out how to maybe and the teams that are
building it or maybe gonna figure out
how to not have any trade-offs nature
exactly I mean you know ultimately I
think as the technology matures I think
there's going to be tremendous
excitement around what that true
potential
the ultimate potential is going to be
but for right now I think the vision is
there
what you have
to think about is again how am I going
to go about this what trade-offs am I
willing to live with because this is
what I want to get out of it and so I
think that's really the thought process
you know what if you're a young company
an entrepreneur and you're thinking well
I'm gonna do this project and gonna do
an IC o---- or whatever that's a
different strategy of strategy all
together and so the blockchain strategy
we we help companies do on that score is
not just the business side but will help
with the tokenization model for example
think token ah mcc's as we say as well
as you know token distribution what does
that look like the marketing effort all
of that that needs to come together in
order to be able to do the IC o---- for
example that's a very different aspect
all together but that's you know on the
strategy side you know my colleague and
I are also as I said mentioned raising a
fund and so for us the fund is really
exciting because we get to look at what
the next generation of Technology offers
and now and of course exactly's do it
so if you think about the internet we we
often refer to a great graphic that
Union Square Ventures put out comparing
the two so if you look at the internet
there was a very thin protocol layer and
a very fat application layer it's
exactly the opposite in the blockchain
there's a very fat protocol there and
it's a very thin application layer for
now I think he'll stick that way or
balance no for now this is where we're
at because people are building the
foundational elements of this right
whether it's you know foundational
protocol and you know for example
interoperability I mean I talk a lot
about that in healthcare so that's a
foundational type of protocol or
foundational platform that we need is
that interoperability element so these
can be things that we need to do right
now so that tomorrow we can actually
build scalable applications right and so
what we're focusing now in the next 24
months is that and that's where we think
the action is at and we're looking at
the enablers of tomorrow let's just from
a very very high level that's kind of
one way to look at it so you really like
the new protocols that are being made
because those protocols can then be used
for farm applications for anything I
mean for many many different areas
any different news cases and so what
we're looking at is that foundational
protocol because you can do many
different things with it and it doesn't
have to be just focusing on one sector
it can be applied in any in any given
sector that you think what the potential
is really exciting in this particular
sector and the adoption is going to be
maybe sooner here than there so that's
where we're going to look at all of
those and say okay where are we gonna go
with this and so what we're betting on
right now is when we start looking at
companies that we're going to be
investing in is exactly that saying
we're the where are the enablers of
tomorrow now that having been said we
will keep our eyes open for like the one
offs that we see and saying what could
be the next big winner even on the
application side and we wouldn't want to
miss out on those kinds of deals either
what about the that was a bit on
protocols what about platforms I can you
know the difference between a platform
is where you can bring many different
people to a how to say enable many
different people to come together to do
something I know it's a very general way
to explain that but think about it from
an ecosystem standpoint a platform can
be where multiple stakeholders can plug
into that and you're enabling let's say
you're in healthcare ok and you're doing
a healthcare platform you want to be
able to have the providers the patient's
the insurance companies maybe even
pharma companies all come together and
you're building this platform which is
sort of able to deal with all the
different components right that's one
application or one one one way to look
at it when you start bringing a lot of
people together on something that's what
a platform does that's what a platform
is supposed to do and so
interoperability is one of those things
where that could be a platform where
you're developing an interoperability
platform where many different people
could come together if you think about a
company that does you know enables api's
for example with many different
stakeholders right in there and makes it
interoperable that's an example of a
platform for example so we're seeing
we're looking at a different people that
are looking at those kinds of problems
and saying ok that might be usable in a
many different areas it's not like it's
just usable in one difference one one
sector it can be applied across many
different sectors and so that's
something that we would look at and
saying well that looks exciting because
it has multiple uses again many people
would use that to do something else
doesn't make sense
yeah what is the we always like to talk
about the balance between the we are one
mentality and the importance of
geopolitical leadership where do you
think that balance lies globally you
mean well the beauty is with blockchain
is that the geopolitical leadership is
in many different areas I think you know
if you look at the ico activity for
example that's a really great area where
you look at you political really
leadership there are many small
countries Switzerland Malta Gibraltar
Estonia Singapore all of these are small
countries basically that are saying our
small locations that are saying we want
to attract a lot of these companies that
are involved in blockchain so they have
these very clear guidelines on what you
need to do in their jurisdiction to be
able to do something like this and
that's a real equalizer I think globally
because in the past I think it's been
where one or two places might have had
that Nexus if you will we've been very
spoiled in Silicon Valley being a nexus
for so much of entrepreneurial activity
I think Silicon Valley is definitely a
big player globally but it's not the
only player and I think that what's
happening across the globe in blockchain
is that a lot of people are sitting up
and taking notice and saying we want to
develop these very clear guidelines so
that it invites people to do certain
activities like I SEOs for example but
if you think of technology itself there
are governments for example that have
banned the icy OS but they haven't
banned the technology they're actually
promoting the technology very heavily
China is one where they said well we
don't want those icy OS we don't want
cryptocurrency necessarily to be there I
mean we don't want that but we want
technology
to the implement so actually the
government is encouraging and supporting
all businesses to take a look at this
just at large and so if you think about
geopolitical leadership and what that
means that means that in order to be a
player in this space you really have to
be all hands on deck everybody on board
with this right and I think that that's
where I think the US has from room to
growth
we're just kind of seeing a very careful
sort of path that the US has taken and
it is the way it is at the moment I'm
just saying that you know in the face of
do political leadership they have to
balance that and saying well if they
want to be a to political leader in this
space they're gonna have to think
through certain things much faster than
they have been and they are trying to
work on it not saying they aren't it's
just that you know there are a lot of
other ecosystems that are moving really
fast into this and so that determines
the face of geopolitical leadership from
that perspective
definitely so give us an explanation
here what is the difference between like
an AI CEO of a company and I CEO of a
country because I CEO of a company I
have like 10 million coins and then I
sell these coins for a penny each or
whatever you might want to sell your
coins for yeah and then that's the
funding that you get for your company I
actually I wish I was as knowledgeable
on the I SEOs for country's crazy you
know it's it's wild right I mean in
there are many countries that are saying
well we need to have a cryptocurrency
for the nation as well I think that you
know it's kind of like maybe it's it's
when you look at cryptocurrency in
general typically what you're looking at
is the reason why you'd want to have
that token right there has to be a
utility value associated with that token
fundamentally right now I'm not talking
about investing in that and it's a
security versus utility I'm not talking
about that conversation what I'm talking
about is fundamentally with a token
you're going to have to have
utility value so why would a government
want that I mean a government could
potentially use that token not only as a
monetary concurrency but it could be a
currency that provides access to
services that are supported by the
government right and it could be housing
it could be medical services it could be
financial services it could be many
different types of services that
government education services there are
many different types of services that a
government could be very interested in
from issuing a token that then gives you
access to those services or anything and
so it's a different model altogether of
thinking about things and so in the
emerging markets that's one of the big
exciting aspects is how do you use
something like this to enable services
to the people that need the services
those tokens for access its access
that's really what you're giving because
otherwise why would you own that now if
you say well I want to own it because
it's gonna go up in value that's
obviously security right but
fundamentally when you think about it it
opens it you're thinking about access to
something to service usually yeah so
what's really exciting is for example
Finland has has adopted I guess their
blockchain identity cards of sorts to
refugees in refugees camps they don't
have a legal identity do you know who
Tony Lin Casserly is for culture you
don't I laughter yeah another interest
but yeah I mean that's an interesting
think about what they have they've got
this identity card of sorts through
blockchain to be able to access services
because they don't have the usual thing
that these citizens of that country have
and so they had to find a different way
of providing service yeah and I'm
thinking wow that's really cool we don't
have that here right and you know it's a
way of providing access to something and
so I think that's the the game changer
here so when you think about why
governments would want it why entities
would want it it's really about
providing access to something right and
it can be again part tanja coming back
to that incentivization as part of that
blockchain that's what's exciting I mean
think about what we give up in order to
have access to email
me email or whatever have an email
account that you're providing data we
become the product exactly precisely
right and so it's not free right you're
actually providing but you don't have
any say in where that data gets
implemented or utilized or mined and so
I mean gdpr is all about that saying you
have the right to say do you have you
authorize the use of this to go towards
a certain thing in a blockchain Society
all of us are incentivized companies as
well as individuals so an individual
might be incentivized to have that token
because it provides access to something
on the flipside the company provides or
pays or access to your data so everybody
sort of wins in this model right right
now you know so much money is being made
out of what we offer up and yes we are
offering it up but sometimes we don't
necessarily understand the breadth of
what we're actually offering or the
depth of the implication around it and
so this is this is a much more conscious
decision making process of what you're
offering up and what you're accessing I
think that's a really that's a
transformational shift in thinking it is
yeah so we had a someone on our show
teaching us I met a Mary it was teaching
us about how if we treated data more
like memory we treated it more like our
memories we would be a little bit more
cautious though more judicious right
yeah this is vigilant in the process
exactly yeah
it has to be a a conscious and a
deliberate sort of thought process right
so I think that's what's exciting is
that we'll all be forced to sort of
think through things a little bit more
deeply and and you know not be so casual
about the way we do something right I
mean we may be still casual I mean
somebody might say I really don't get
you know who about this I'm just gonna
let them do whatever they want that's
fine that's your choice but the point is
you should have that choice and so
that's it's all about having those
conscious choices which I think from a
society standpoint I mean we're
definitely at that point where we need
to offer more conscious choices about
things
let's ask you a couple questions now
we'll ask you a couple of our simulation
questions so we asked you about the
geopolitical one that's one sounds a
little a little a little interesting and
hard to answer we also asked about
wealth and equality and this is oh this
is tough this is a tough question what
do you what do you think about
exponential technology kind of
increasing the wealth and equality even
though everyone at the bottom slowly
coming up the ones at the top are going
really fast well here's what's exciting
on that front um if you think of we
actually recently supported the campaign
for Ben Bartlett do you know Ben he's
the vice mayor of Berkeley okay he ran
recently for for state assembly and he
has written paper about this as well as
evangelized on this topic saying if we
all had to be paid for our data that
might end up being roughly about a
universal basic income we've talked
about the tiny notes on the show kind of
we know right and so you think about
that it's actually one that after that
yeah well he didn't author that concept
that he said that that's something
that's achievable and he is actually
pioneering the use of municipal bonds
you know as well and so again
transformative thinking visionary
thinking in local government I mean we
need that right and so when you think
about equality when you think about
access and you think about you know
equalizing or democratizing access to
various things again I think the future
of this technology is pretty pretty
profound when you think about how people
are going to go about thinking about
certain things because right now we
don't even know what our data is being
used for if you had the knowledge of
what that data was being used for and
you had the chance to be incentivized to
opt in for something and somebody paid
you for that you could very easily be
making roughly on the on the order of a
user ubi right and so that is
transformative and is thinking and then
and then you know it provides you not
only access to - so having say a token
that comes
part of that that conversation as well
now you have access to things that you
might need like health care or education
or housing or what have you so when you
think about a democratization
equalization you know in society I think
these are things that we can start
thinking about saying there are creative
ways that we can solve from the problems
that plague us today yeah even from a
society standpoint
yep I like how your answers are circling
back to blockchain time because it is
very true that it will
the push for decentralization and the
push for transparency will make a
radical shift on inequality and a
radical shift even on young
globalization will that's it's that's
good that's the whole social good aspect
of things right yeah we you know we're
really sitting at the cusp of something
really exciting here fundamentally
exciting that's why I love talking about
it because again I don't think I've seen
a technology that's gotten this excited
about so many different aspects and
layers to this right whether you're
talking about society and social impact
whether you're talking about you know
just fundamentally different ways of
thinking about things we need that you
know we can't be stuck in the rut that
we've been right but the internet was
created for a very different purpose it
was created for open communication email
is a first application onion internet
right and so it's a very different
purpose all together and you know the
purpose of blockchain is something
different and so obviously there's
things that we have to do to get better
at certain things and there's there's
things that we need to work at but
fundamentally I think it has the ability
to just solve some of the some of the
systemic challenges that we've had so
far what do you thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world in terms of
come again for context in general in
just in general I think well I happen to
think this is a thinking global kind of
mindset that I've always had since I was
a little girl my personal story is that
I'm I was born in India I was raised in
Morocco I grew up in Tangier in the
Straits of Gibraltar but across from
Gibraltar as a matter of fact
interestingly enough how that's on the
map now and that was a gateway kind of
mentality a mindset gateway culture east
meets west north and south and there you
know so I think it my whole background
has been about thinking global and so
what I really get excited about is when
I think about that one world
you know I don't know if we'll ever
achieve that capability of being one
world but I think that that's really
what we need to be doing and thinking
about if you've seen anything about
astronauts that have gone up into space
and looked at the Big Blue Marble and
think about the profound impact that
that image had on their manner of
thinking and looking at this big marvel
where we live as one world I think
that's a pretty pretty profound concept
and I think that you know too often you
know we're here and you have our little
bubbles whatever our microcosm is and we
stay in that little microcosm and don't
think beyond it and think about what the
person next door is doing what the city
next door is doing what the next country
is doing with the next planet or what
the next continent is doing what the
next planet is doing I think that whole
thinking about all of us if we really
thought carefully as a human race and
thought about one world I think that's
something that's really beautiful it's
very profound and it's something that I
think about because the whole point of
connecting these ecosystems in the way
that I do using technology that's
something that gets me really excited
because it's a way that I see technology
being able to build bridges across
different ecosystems in a way that we
often don't do from a cultural and
societal perspective since we're at the
Women in Technology summit what do you
think's a good way to maximize the
potential of women and young women into
our world um I think that the you know
the opportunities to get involved with
great emerging technologies whatever
that might be I think the opportunities
are tremendous I'd love to see women
play a larger role in leading the way
and pioneering you know and foreing into
uncharted territories I think that we
have an amazing capability for working
creatively through problems I once heard
a talk
about a physiological aspect of women
that many women have have a wider corpus
collosum and that the brain is just
wired for interconnectivity between the
hemispheres and that we have this
amazing ability to do this and what I'd
love to see is for all of us to have
that opportunity to work collaboratively
together and to incentivize this kind of
behavior as well that's a great future
for us that you know we can all
participate in together it's not just
about women I often talk about the fact
that you know the thing about our human
races that we are so so diverse and so
you know not always is that diversity
celebrated not all of that is made
available we are not often included and
so what I'd like to look at from my
particular perspective as being an
immigrant in this country from being a
woman of color so to speak and I look at
the world around me and saying well
there's just a lot of unjust ways that
things are being done and so the greater
tomorrow is by bringing everybody to the
table and being active participants in a
decision-making process by having women
being involved not just in the
technology but leading the way in
technology because I think what we bring
is a very different unique type of
leadership that I think the world
absolutely needs so I'm looking forward
to that I mean looking forward to that
being part of that conversation I am a
part of that conversation in MIDI for it
to even greater things yes do you think
we're alone in the cosmos definitely not
definitely it's I mean the evidence is
just astounding my younger son is an
aspiring astrophysicist and he's an
interesting your year in high school and
you know he is looking at the the
heavens beyond I'm saying you know you
there's too many of us I think who are
big proponents of we can't have such an
arrogant view that we're unique in this
universe right or even multiverse for
that matter I mean that's different on
which theory you you you you know
embrace but I think that you know even
there's an our galaxy alone so let alone
the multitudes of other galaxies that
exist it's so arrogant to think that
we're alone in this world it's just not
possible at all physically not possible
you know whether we cross paths that's a
different question all together
you know either another race is so
beyond us that they look at us and say
oh my god they're so backward we don't
even wanna interact with them or they
might be not as ahead as we are and so
they can't interact I mean so the timing
of things obviously that's a big thing
are we going to need that other race I
don't know but are we the only race
absolutely not
do you think we're in a simulation Wow
blue pill red pill moment sometimes it
feels like it doesn't it I mean
sometimes I think there's moments I mean
think about those moments for you to
make it deja Vu's I think what in what
exactly about the deja vu
I have sometimes really strong deja Vu's
even just amazed me saying down to the
last detail of that moment thing I've
lived this moment before this has passed
by before this is not the first time
I've gone through this this is not the
first time I've said this or what have
you you know contextually as well as
explicitly and that's always just makes
me sit up and thinking well that was
different this is this is not just a
teacher because I actually experienced
this before so what was that all about
right and so those moments that you just
go wow hmm maybe we are in a simulation
I think that you know sometimes things
just happen the way they do in an in a
in a manner in which you personally
could not have orchestrated it that way
and you couldn't have had the foresight
to have it happen that particular way
and so those are the moments that you
think hmm maybe there is something
behind that what about you
do you really like deja vu yeah I feel
like one of the coolest things to go
back to yes yeah well if we could
reverse the time to go back to a moment
yeah it would be really interesting to
aback you can usually just cook a pause
and just observe it yeah what is this
feeling great oh yeah cuz it goes by
just like three seconds it's just too
fast
yeah I think you know it's not just even
not um in in my culture we talk about
multiple lifetimes right and there's
there's no those moments too along the
same vein maybe not quite exactly but in
the same vein of it you know you meet
somebody and you say my god you know
just met this person I feel like I've
known him for millennia you know what
was that connection all about I mean
it's like two souls that need that had
crossed paths before that spend time in
a different life time before and you
know Wow
that was not real I mean there's no way
that I could know this person so well
but I do I know them I understand them
right and so those moments of multiple
lifetimes I think also those are the
flashbacks I think in through history
and then those are moments of pause
mmm-hmm yeah that's pretty cool yeah
there's so much to unpacking what exists
outside of the 3d world
definitely so let's uh let's tap into
that fabric to figure out exactly what's
going on Monica thank you so much for
joining us thank you it's real pleasure
P and great questions by the way really
enjoyed this thank you yeah we really
enjoyed you teaching us thank you so
much I'm coming out of the show thank
you so much really appreciate it
yeah and we learned a lot we learned a
lot Oh blockchain we learned a lot about
supplications the way that helps
businesses as well as the different
protocols that are being built for the
future you got me thinking about Pharma
and healthcare and all the insurance
applications manufacturing applications
man you got me thinking so much about
that and the price 30 would at forty
thirty seven thousand thirty four
thousand thirty seven thousand I think
projects that are out there that are
this growing that's that is status
that's pilots and let's see where
they're gonna be leveraging blockchain
and yeah and how we're gonna I think are
going beyond pilots but yeah that's
exciting yeah and how that's going to
impact transparency in the world and so
much more
so everyone if you guys had a good time
definitely give us a share the content
other people get talking more about
block chaining you're talking about more
about the impact that's making on the
world subscribe below give us a comment
below with your thoughts we'd love to
hear from you also go create with this
content don't just consume but go make
something or make a video go make a blog
post about it talk to other people maybe
start a company and lastly join us on
patreon so we can continue coming in
great places like the Women in
Technology summit here and continue
having fantastic conversation and
sharing that content with you so thank
you so much everyone
much love thank you
you